vous devez traverser le 18e pour aller
travailler et vous dit peut être une
femme dans le nord-est parisien c'est
devenu mission impossible car seulement
de rue au quotidien je me fait cracher
dessus insultés on a même une vidéo que
vous avez réaliser vous même si j'ai
bien compris on va le regarder
mais bouge mais creuse sais vous allez
me dire on
vous laissera tranquille
c'est là me faire ouais c'est l'enfer je
pense qu'en plus ces deux jeux parmi
bien d'autres c'est la dernière on va
dire c'était en l'homme prenne le micro
la dernière séquence était en 2021 et la
première c'était en 2019
comment vous dire que quand j'entends
madame la député du loiret du coup qui
ne vit sûrement pas proximité de ce
genre de scène et madame qui
addictologues et qui apparemment a
renoncé à soigner
je suis vraiment scandalisé parce que
moi je vis là-bas de base c'est toute
une zone qui est très sensible qui est
compliqué en tant que femme j'ai
toujours eu des problèmes pour pour
vivre dans le nord-est de paris rien
qu'à cause déjà des trafiquants de
drogue mais aussi des trafiquants de
cigarettes et autres qui qui juste
qu'ils sont statiques dans la rue on
propose des pass on m'interpelle
on voit là on m'insulte quand je refuse
de donner mon numéro de téléphone
enfin les salles de shoot aggrave encore
ces problèmes que vous constatez depuis
des années
en tout cas ça n'apporte pas de
solutions d'accord clairement je suis
contre les salles de shoot parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est une salle de
consommation à moindre risque c'est une
salle on consomme de la drogue et le
pire en puces c'est que les toxicomanes
qui vont dans ces salles ils ne sont pas
forcés de rester à l'intérieur pour
s'injecter c'est à dire que quand ils
sont en plein trip et ben ils le font
dans la rue et qu'on me dit que les
associations de riverains enfin trois
sur quatre étaient
heureux de l'environnement aux abords de
la salle de shoot mais je me dis mais en
fait à qui on a demandé d'ailleurs j'ai
regardé cette étude elle et les enfin
qu'on a demandé l'avis au riz brun
c'était en
2017-2018 max enfin on n'a pas demandé
récemment donc j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi en plus en quoi en quoi
franchement ça améliore notre cadre de
vie quand les enfants sur le chemin de
l'école ils voient des toxicomanes qui
se piquent avec des sangles dans le
cadre bas de des drogues qui s'injectent
le crack s'assume mais c'est après ces
voix là c'est des dérives comme des
hommes qui se masturbe en pleine rue
c'est des personnes qui vont déféquer
uriner en pleine rue devant tout le
monde d'accord c'est aussi des des
enfants qui se font agresser par exemple
il ya un enfant en poussette vers la
chapelle qui s'était fait agresser alors
qu' il était dans sa poussée par une
toxicomane qui qui voilà qui fait quand
on entend cette florilège
et on pourrait continuer à l'infini et
que je reprends une déclaration bonne
dame janvier nous dit il faut
privilégier des implantations dans les
quartiers où la consommation existent
déjà donc pour ne pas créer de nouveaux
lieux de fixation c'est le cas de le
dire d'ailleurs ce qu'ils s'assurent
mais voyez quand on voit ce témoignage
c'est qu'on se dit bah alors il ya des
quartiers qui apparemment parce que les
toxicos sont là ont vocation à
recueillir toutes toutes les avanies
toutes les nuisances et quand je parle
de nuisance le mot est faible parce que
la cdc des actes criminels non mais bien
sûr et je ne nie pas du tout la sécurité
et la difficulté de vivre dans ce genre
de quartier ce que je veux dire c'est
que ces salles ces espaces de
consommation ils ont aussi été créés
vous et vous l'avez rappelé pour les
deux raisons de santé tranquillité pour
justement
emmener un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont dans les rues et qui ont tous
les comportements vous évoquez ça je
sais ce qu on a constaté aussi et pour
finalement améliorer la situation du
quartier pas tout régler encore une fois
mais ce qu'on constate et c'est le cas
dans les autres villes européennes qui
ont mis en place un espace de
consommation c'est que la situation
s'améliore et moi c'est ce que m'ont dit
vous vous demandiez à quel moment les
avaient interrogés nous les a interrogés
au mois de juillet c'est ce que m'ont
dit trois de ses quatre collectifs ils
m'ont dit d'ailleurs au moment de la
crise sanitaire la salle a fermé ou un
moment a réduit ses horaires et on a vu
réapparaître les problèmes qu'il y avait
avec avant la salle c'est à dire des
seringue partout des personnes qui
déambulent dans le quartier qui hurlent
qui voit là et donc je ne dis pas que ça
a tout réglé je dis juste que ça
améliorer sahara et du monde dit
personne se shoote dans la salle et sort
sur la voie publique en quoi s'améliore
je dirais par exemple ou tout simplement
vous avez des travailleurs sociaux qui
font des maraudes c'est à dire qu'ils
vont rencontre de ces diverses taxes
comme al parce que vous évoquez vous la
question de la prise en charge en
réalité et vous avez raison c'est
d'ailleurs nous une des deux conditions
qu'on a donné à la poursuite de ces
expérimentations c'est le fait qu'on met
plus d'argent sur les dispositifs de
sevrage de prise en charge médico
sociale parce qu'effectivement ça doit
être qu'une étape et qu'un outil parmi
d'autres il faut régler le problème de
façon plus profonde et on manque de
moyens je suis d'accord avec vous là
dessus mais donc quand vous avez un
espace comme ça vous avez les travers
sociaux qui peuvent aller chercher les
personnes toxicomanes qui sinon son
livret qui ont la formation poupe parce
que ce sont des gens qui sont dans des
situations de détresse et parfois de
violence qui peuvent les emmener là et
qui ensuite peuvent travailler sur un
hébergement travailler sur une prise en
charge sanitaire et mettre en place un
accompagnement mais est encore une fois
je ne dis pas que ça règle tous les
problèmes